alors mes chers collègues vous le savez
au printemps dernier la délégation des
droits des enfants a mené un cycle
d'audition autour de la petite enfance
nous étions alors précurseurs en la
matière car certain que la question de
la petite enfance mais elle n'est pas la
seule méritait une attention
particulière nous avons entre autres
interrogé l'Association des maires de
France les professionnels de la petite
enfance mais nous avions également
auditionné Ligas qui venait alors de
rendre son rapport sur les crèches
il nous avait été présenté les
conclusions de sa mission d'évaluation
sur les processus et les mesures mises
en œuvre afin de garantir la sécurité et
la bientraitance des enfants accueillis
en crèche ainsi que ses principales
recommandations ce rapport faisait le
constat d'une qualité d'accueil
particulièrement hétérogène d'une
intégration des connaissances sur le
jeune enfant variaable sur les
établissements d'une pénurie de
professionnel de la petite enfance
résultant de la perte d'attractivité de
ses métiers et d'une formation
insuffisante ainsi qu'un manque d'
information au parents sur les risques
de maltraitance et les voies de recours
existant en cas de difficulté cet état
des lieux a été suivi de l'apparution de
deux ouvrage critiques sur les crèches
privées d'ailleurs largement inspiré de
ce rapport de Ligas nous disposions nous
disposions dès lors d'une littérature
fournie et il m'impimportait que la
délégation qui a eu l'opportunité de
traiter une partie du sujet puisse
poursuivre son travail c'est pourquoi la
délégation a souhaité approfondir cette
question et a donc chargé mesdames
Michel Peron Isabelle Santiago de
conduire une mission flash sur les
perspectives d'évolution de la prise en
charge des enfants dans les crèches ce
temps très bref devait permettre de
prendre la mesure des modalités déjà
misise en œuvre c'est à la suite du
rapport IGAS fournir des pistes
d'amélioration et proposer des axes de
réflexion le tout dans le timing des
projets de finances afin de pouvoir être
si possible dans les mesures très
rapidement avant d'entendre nos
rapporteurs je tiens tout d'abord à
saluer leur travail comme vous le verrez
dans le rapport qu'elles ont remis elles
ont auditionné très largement sur un
temps contraint et je les en remercie je
tiens également à à remercier notre
administratrice qui les a accompagné
pour pour ce travail alors je souhaite
vous rappeler que sur le sujet de la
petite enfance et plus spécifiquement
sur la question des crèches nous aurons
également l'opportunité d'entendre la
ministre la semaine prochaine qui
viendra donc s'exprimer par rapport au
rapport que vous êtes en que vous allez
nous présenter tout à l'heure alors
mesdames les rapporteurs je vous laisse
la parole et nous aurons l'opportunité
comme d'ab de vous interroger à l'issue
sur votre rapport je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente cher
pine madame la rapporteur chère Isabelle
chers collègues je tiens tout d'abord à
saluer et remercier très chaleureusement
notre administratrice et les services de
la délégation aux droits des enfants qui
ont fait preuve d'une grande
disponibilité et aide lors de cette
mission flash dans les délais nous
restreignés mes chers collègues avec
Madame Santiago nous sommes fiers de
vous présenter ce rapport nous avons
vraiment mené cette mission main dans la
main sans désaccords le rapport est donc
à l'image de cette entente les constats
et recommandations qui le composent sont
donc communs à toutes les deux cette
mission flash comme son nom l'indique sé
étalé sur un délai d'un mois nous avons
tout de même pu mener une vingtaine
d'auditions nous remercions donc
l'ensemble des personnes auditionnées et
les personnes nous ayant fourni une
contribution écrite qui ont répondu à
nos demandes je tiens à signaler que
l'ensemble des personnes que nous avons
contacté ont accepté d'échanger avec
nous en transparence et ont répondu à
toutes nos questions un regret toutefois
de la mission et je suis sûre que ma
collègue est d'accord avec moi et et que
nous n'avons pas pu étudier le cas
spécifique des outr-emères enfin je
souhaite saluer les professionnels et
tous les acteurs de terrain qui œuvrent
chaque jour avec beaucoup d'abnégation
dans l'accompagnement de nos enfants le
rapport est composé de 54
recommandations nous ne reviendrons pas
sur chacune d'entre elles sinon cette
présentation se prolongerait sur la
durée mais Isabelle Santiago et moi
sommes à votre disposition pour répondre
à vos questions mais également pour
prolonger l'échange avec ceux qui le
souhaitent cette mission s'est attachée
à dépasser la seule problématique des
crèches qui ne peuvent s'envisager seul
mais bien travers une vision plus
globale autour de l'enfant qui se doit
être au cœur de nos préoccupations
Isabelle Santiago reviendra plus en
profondeur sur cet enjeu dans ma
présentation je m'attarderai plus
précisément sur les professionnels et
sur les contrôle des structures le
rapport de Ligas remis en avril dernier
pointait de nombreuses défaillances au
sein de certaines structures ainsi
qu'une pénurie inquiétante de
professionnels nous nous sommes attachés
Isabelle et moi a auditionné l'ensemble
des acteurs issus du public du privé
lucratif et non lucratif aussi bien des
gestionnaires que des professionnels de
terrain du secteur de la petite enfance
mais aussi des universitaires et
administrations afin de rendre un
éclairage général de la situation
actuelle nos recommandations sont donc
un reflet de ces auditions et les
arbitrages que nous avons pris sont
éclairés par l'ensemble de ces échanges
je souhaite donc avant d'entrer dans les
détails saluer l'ensemble des
professionnels une nouvelle fois du
secteur qui face à l'ensemble des
différentes sorties littéraires ou
médiatiques voit leur profession mise à
mal profession pourtant de premier
recours comme nous l'a bien prouvé la
période de pandémie que nous avons
vécu le constat principal est une
pénurie actuelle très inquiétante
puisqu'il manque aujourd'hui environ
10000 professionnels pour garantir le
maintien et la qualité des places en
crèche actuell et bien plus inquiétant
encore c'est 20000 professionnels qui
partiront à la retraite d'ici
2027 certains parlent même de crise de
pénurie annoncée puisque les objectifs
d'ouverture de mode de garde ne
coincident pas de très loin avec
l'ouverture de places de formation pour
les différentes professions du secteur à
titre d'exemple entre 2011 et 2021 il y
a eu une augmentation de 31 % du nombre
d'ouverture de plac au sein des eagie
face à cela le nombre de places de for
formation pour des éducateurs jeunes
enfants ont augmenté de 7 % en remarque
belle et bien un
décalage aussi selon nous il est
nécessaire de mettre en place au plus
vite un plan d'urgence pour la formation
des professionnels du secteur de la
petite enfance ce plan d'urgence doit
également s'accompagner de la mise en
place d'objectifs de formation par
l'État après concertation avec les
régions qui sont chef de fil pour la
formation et d'une grande campagne pour
faire connaître ces métiers qui sont de
réelle vocation pour les jeunes mais
aussi pour des reconversions
professionnelles le contenu des
formations doit également être revu
aujourd'hui l'enseignement reste trop
théorique et la place du stage notamment
et minime pour l'obtention du diplôme
néanmoins si le stage ne se passe pas
bien il nous paraît inenvisageable que
la personne puisse être diplômée et
ensuite s'occuper de bébés et
d'enfants le contenu de la formation
théorique se doit d'être également
modifié et actualisé en faisant plus de
place au neurosciences au soutien à la
parentalité à l'éveil culturel et à la
prise en charge des enfants en situation
de handicap plus urgent nous portons
comme recommandation la suppression des
formation en ligne type CAP petite
enfance par Internet dès la rentrée de
2024 il nous est inconcevable et nous
considérons même dangereux que des bébés
ou des enfants soient laissés au soin de
personnes n'ayant jamais pratiquer
auprès d'enfants pendant leur formation
enfin nous avons pris comme
recommandation forte que nous souhaitons
plus de personnes
diplômées au sein des structures le
décret dit Morano a diminué les
exigences de qualification des
professionnels nous sommes passés de 50
à 40 % d'effectifs diplômés nous
souhaitons à minima rehausser cette part
à 60 % des professionnels puis
l'interdiction progressive de tout
recrutement de personnes non diplômées
la formation continue est également un
levier essentiel cette formation
continue doit avoir une place importante
dans les carrières et ne plus être une
variable formation annulée en raison
d'une absence d'un collègue ou avoir
lieu sur des temps non travaillés le
weekend notamment nous devons également
associer à cette rénovation de la
formation des professionnels une
augmentation de l'attractivité de ces
métiers de la petite enfance tout
d'abord à travers une amélioration des
conditions matérielles de travail qui
passe principalement par la réduction
des tailles des groupes en mettant en
place un taux d'encadrement d'un
professionnel pour C enfants lorsque les
enfants marchent et d'un professionnel
pour trois enfants pour les bébés nous
pensons également que le taux
d'encadrement doit être calculé au
niveau des groupes d'enfants et non au
niveau de l'établissement nous pensons
qu'il est également essentiel de
reconnaître du temps de travail hors
enfant le le mode de financement actuel
ne permet pas de reconnaître les temps
hors enfant il est nécessaire pour les
professionnels d'avoir des temps
d'échange de formation de concertation
et d'échange de pratique ces TS
d'échange ne peuvent avoir lieu sur
l'heure du déjeuner quand les enfants
font la sieste ni sur des temps de
fermeture de la structure un des leviers
principaux d'attractivité est également
celui des salaires les gestionnaires
publics et privés essaient de proposer
des salaires supérieurs au SMIC
néanmoins la inflation et les
augmentations du SMIC rendent leur les
augmentations difficiles une fois encore
le mode de financement actuel PSU et
plafond de 10 € par jour not d' augmenté
depuis 2013 ne permet pas de
revalorisation significative dans le
privé cette question est renvoyée au
dialogue social et notamment à l'an
relatif au salaire nous serons attentiv
à ce que le sujet soit bel et bien
abordé en effet les métiers de la petite
enfance sont très peu représentés au
niveau syndical ils sont pourtant des
métier de premier recours dans le public
l'État se doit de prévoir des
revalorisations salariales et donc de
montrer l'exemple tous les efforts que
nous devons porter pour rendre ces
lettres de noblesse à ces métiers
doivent également s'associer à un
meilleur accompagnement des
professionnels dans mon rapport sur la
PMI rendu en 2019 19 je préconisais
alors la mise en place d'un référenti
d'un référentiel national sur la partie
bâtimentaire et souligner le gaspillage
de tant de professionnels PMI pour la
vérification des critères bâtimentaires
des structures au sein de ce rapport
nous souhaitons la mise en place d'un
référentiel sur la qualité des
structures ce référentiel doit poser les
bases de ce que l'on attend à minima des
structures qui accueillent le public
vulnérabl que sont les jeunes enfants
nous prenons même la mise en place d'un
label qualité au niveau national et dont
le respect est vérifié régulièrement
nous devons repenser cette culture du
contrôle
la PMI ne doit plus être vue comme la
méchante qui vient pour fermer la
structure mais bel et bien comme un
atout et un contact de premierers choix
pour accompagner les structures et
répondre aux questionnements des
professionnels il faut avant tout
redonner aux PMI les moyens de leurs
actions comme je le recommandais au sein
de mon rapport de 2019 la PMI doit se
recentrer sur son expertise et donc se
concentrer sur la qualité et
l'accompagnement des professionnels
enfin en 2010 19 je recommandais la mise
en place d'expérimentation de transfert
de tout ou partie de la compétence
relative aux eage à la CAF ma
recommandation portait principalement
sur le transfert de la partie
bâtimentaire à la CAF une
expérimentation est actuellement en
cours en haute savoir dont les résultats
sont positifs les PMI et les CAF
travaillent de concert les
professionnels des structures et des PMI
ont renoué un contact qualitatif nous
proposons donc de généraliser cette
expérimentation et je vais maintenant
laisser la parole à ma collègue
corapporteur Isabelle Santiago
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues madame la rapporteur cher
Michel ce fut évidemment un immense
plaisir de mener cette mission flash
courte mais intense
et remercier bien évidemment madame
l'administratrice qui nous a accompagné
et je trouve que que les préconisations
que nous faisons relèvent évidemment de
notre entente puisque même sur les
sujets sur lesquel nous avions aucun
aucune difficulté à porter ensemble des
sujets de profonde réforme et c'est je
crois très important dans une CO
coprésidence de ce rapport d'avoir eu
cette intelligence collective de porter
le sujet avec ce Briot je dirais qui est
éit notre entente mais aussi l'entente
sur le fond et qui me paraît essentiel
dans le cadre de ce rapport d'évolution
des prises en charge donc des enfants
dans les crèches donc à mon tour de vous
dire que sur ce sujet je pense et je
l'ai dit à
plusieurs échanges que j'ai pu avoir et
compris dans les auditions il faut du
courage politique pour changer
réellement de paradigme en France et
cela va se se traduire par des
changements en matière de politique
publique de la petite enfance donc agir
tô doit être notre boussole comme dans
de nombreux pays qui l'ont compris bien
avant nous dans les modèles bien sûr il
y a les pays nordiques mais aussi plus
récemment le Québec qui avec la
présentation d'un mémoire au ministre
des Finances dans le cadre des
consultations prébudgétaires de 2023 et
2024 on fait
adopter une préconisation sur un
ensemble de sujets de tout à fait
transversaux et qui euh relie à peu près
l'ensemble de nos propositions aussi ça
va on pousse tous dans les pays sur
ce ce champ de la petite enfance en
pensant évidemment d'abord de se centrer
sur les besoins fondamentaux des enfants
investir sur la petite enfance c'est
aussi agir pour l'avenir donc nos
préconisation se veulent être un
tournant dans cette prise de conscience
et comme je viens de vous l'indiquer
dans de nombreux pays on a pu voir des
nombreuses modifications qui sont en
cours ou qui sont déjà à
l'œuvre nous avons nous en France eu de
différents depuis une vingtaine d'années
de nombreux sujets autour de ces
question de nombreux décrets Michel en a
parlé une déréglementation du secteur
donc Ligas avait pu aussi le pointer le
rapport de liigas dernièrement des
études nombreuses de nos experts en
France y compris les recherches
international qui font référence en la
matière sur les neurosciences donc le le
développement aujourd'hui des
connaissances en neurosciences a permis
de mieux connaître les besoins pour
l'enfant pour favoriser son déplacement
et son développement pardon les modes
d'accueil de la petite enfance constitue
le premier lieu de socialisation
institué hors de la famille il contribue
ainsi grandement à la santé des enfants
et à leur développement de ce fait il
est évidemment primordial de prendre en
considération les apports des chercheurs
pour comprendre les besoins des enfants
le rapport donc de madame Martin
Blanchet en 2017 insistait déjà sur le
besoin de tout enfant de disposer d'une
base de sécurité affective suffisante
pour s'épanouir s'ouvrir au monde
acquérir des habilités physiques
physiologique langagière d'estime de soi
et de relation aux autres la démarche de
consensus sur les besoins fondamentaux
de l'enfant reconnaît ainsi les besoins
de sécurité de celui-ci comme un
métabesoin qui condition la satisfaction
des besoins fondamentaux universels du
petit enfant Boris hulnick plus
récemment dans son rapport de septembre
2020 sur les 1000 premiers jours de
l'enfant soulignait que la croissance la
plus importante du cerveau de l'enfant
se déroule pendant la fin de la
grossesse et les deux premières années
de sa vie le plus souvent le parent crée
un cercle virtueux autour de l'enfant ou
au contact de l'adulte avec lequel il
rentre en relation développe donc des
compétences sociales indispensables à
son développement cognitif en ce qu'elle
permettent l'exploration et les
apprentissages son apport a également
été de de se saisir et de montrer au
grand public qu'un enfant de moins de 1
an et un enfant de 3 ans n'ont pas les
mêmes besoins alors qu'auparavant
l'enfant était conçu comme un tout
unitaire et et l'ensemble de ces
éléments sont importants sur y compris
l'évolution de ce qu'on va proposer en
modification profonde à cette effet la
la satisfaction de ces besoins
fondamentaux doit constituer la boussole
de modalité de l'accueil des crèches de
la même manière il nous indique qu'en
raison du manque du respect des besoins
fondamentaux de l'enfant dans son plus
jeune âge 10 % de la population générale
serait affecté de trouble du
neurodveloppement du
neurodéveloppement il est donc
nécessaire de faire évoluer les
modalités d'accueil de jeunes enfants en
crèche à la fois sur les besoins
fondamentaux et évidemment mais aussi
pour le repérage de différentes
problématiques comme les troubles
autistiques qui pourrai être décelé
comme ça se fait au Québec par un
dépistage précoce à partir de 18 mois et
qui est universelle qui concerne
évidemment tous les enfants et il
ressort évidemment que de l'ensemble de
tous ces travaux que les bébés ont des
besoins effectifs et affectifs
spécifiques qu'ils doivent tisser des
relations de confiance et sinon ça
impacte
lourdement la construction psychique il
peut les mettre en danger à ce titre le
principe de référence et c'est là que
c'est important parce que ça fait le
lien avec ce que disait Michel sur les
formations le principe de référence est
particulièrement important pour les
crèches donc stabilité des équipes aussi
au sein des structures qui les
accueillent l'enfant a besoin qu'un
adulte identifié prenne soin de lui par
des expérience répété du quotidien qui
lui permett de prendre confiance en lui
et vis-à-vis du monde d'EXE extérieur
nous le savons la petite enfance donc a
besoin de cette référence de l'adulte
pour construire ce cercle de sécurité
une partie des crèches malheureusement
le néglige parce que c'est le sujet du
personnel de manière globale et c'est
pour ça que nous proposons des profondes
réformes en formation initiale etue et
pour stabilité redonner du sens y
compris au travail qu'ils ont et donc
évidemment souhaiter une dynamique
autour de ses emplois parce que le
changement fréquent de personnel ou
d'espace ne sont pas du tout compatibles
avec tout ce que nous savons aujourd'hui
sur les neurosciences des enfants dans
leur développement donc ils ont besoin
de repères et nous on a besoin que ces
enfants éent une figure d'attachement
qui permet le sur le temps long de
pouvoir être pris en charge dans des
meilleures conditions les modes
d'accueil donc doivent répondre avant
tout aux besoins incompressibles du tout
petit et non uniquement au besoins des
parents accueill comme un client pour
certaines crèches lucratives qui dont
l'enfant évidemment est toujours
accompagné du mieux possible il nous
disent tous ça mais on sait aussi que
c'est beaucoup plus complexe et que les
neurosciences aujourd'hui doivent être
au cœur de cette politique publique nous
savons donc que la plupart des pays
nordiques je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure ont compris que la petite
enfance est capitale et sera la société
de demain ces pays ont mené des
réflexions profondes bien avant nous sur
ce sujet ils ont eu le courage politique
y compris de modifier et d'organiser
toute leur société autour des besoins
fondamentaux de l'être humain quand il
est le plus petit et donc le plus
vulnérable comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure le Québec se lance aussi sur ces
grandes réformes le bénéfice il est
immense pour l'enfant qui se va se
développer dans un socle de sécurité et
de confiance et nous nous invitons
évidemment la France à faire la même
chose et donc à ce que ça puisse
s'irriguer dans l'ensemble de nos
propositions qui évidemment vont
s'irriguer dans nos territoires cela
pose évidemment la question de
l'organisation des temps celui de la
famille de la parentalité de la vie
professionnelle le temps des villes
comme c'est le cas dans des villes
labellisées villes amis des enfants par
laamf et l'UNICEF qui sont aussi des
bonnes pratiques pour un ensemble de
sujet autour de l'enfance donc la
réponse des pays nordiques a reposé
globalement sur le partage de la
responsabilité d'élever le petit enfant
entre les deux parents avec un canger
parental long et bien rémunéré durant
lequel les lieux accueil par enfant sont
souvent pour qu'il puisse s'il le désire
ne pas rester isolé être soutenu
accompagné dans sa parentalité un devoir
d'égalité et d'accompagnement de
l'enfant dans sa singularité celle de sa
famille qui n'en pas douté nous le
savons elle est toujours singulière elle
est toujours propre à son histoire et à
la composition familiale c'est à cet
ensemble de conditions que nous devons
répondre et nous nos préconisations vont
dans ce sens y compris sur l'allongement
du congé par parental à 1 an bien
rémunéré sur un modèle que l'on propose
de type celui qui vient d'être fait en
Allemagne autour de 67 70 % du du
dernier revenu au niveau avant le congé
on demande un congé de maternité qui lui
irait plus loin aujourd'hui de 10
semaines il irait à 12 semaines donc on
est vraiment sur une politique globale
où on voit et on souhaite que l'ensemble
des enfants puisse être accompagn que la
parentalité prent toute sa place et les
crèches en fait elles ne peuvent
s'engager seules sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets donc on souhaite une politique
globale de la petite enfance et dans les
préconisations que je vais vous lire
bien évidemment c'est les pratiques
aussi individuel sur un ensemble
collectif sur lequel nous souhaitons
avoir des réponses évidemment importante
un vrai changement de paradigme en fait
en fait on veut vraiment que la
souffrance de certains enfants qui a été
vu dans les rapports de Ligas qui a été
documenté par des documentaires mais
aussi des livres qui ont beaucoup
travaillé sur ces sujets-l et qui ont pu
en faire écho dans notre société qu'en
fait cette page se tourne et qu'on se
tourne vers la priorité les besoins
fondamentaux de l'enfant donc ce rapport
comme je vous l'ai dit vous propose des
préconisations on souhaite que ces
préconisations ne soient pas euh en fait
juste une liste de recommand tion mais
qu'elles irriguent nos politiques
publiques pour cela je pense qu'avec
Michel nous connaissant on va rien
lâcher on est plutôt en général assez
enthousiaste pour poursuivre le champ
des échanges et vous dire que dans les
choses les plus globales que l'on
souhaite bien évidemment il y a des
recommandations qui nécessitent de
positionner aujourd'hui très clairement
la petite enfance au sommet des
priorités en politique publique pour
agir tôt et préparer l'avenir ça se
traduit par plusieurs éléments comme on
vous l'a dit le congé de maternité soit
reporté et en tout cas de 2 semaines
supplémentaires avec 12 semaines en
post-natal on on soutient la nécessité
de mettre en place un congé parental
d'un an à prendre entre parents et
rémunéré à 67 % du salaire inférieur du
bonus et des points de retraite inspiré
du modèle allemand qui s'est fait et qui
s'est mis en place dans ce modèle là de
12 mois ETIB possibilité d'aller jusqu'à
24 mois ça c'est pour l'exemple allemand
avec une rémunération moindre en tout
cas nous souhaitons que ce sujet soit
aborder et que le travail puisse se
faire y compris les négociations pour
commencer à regarder les choses de très
très près on souhaite particulièrement
que il y ait une réforme sur le fond au
niveau des financements puisque que du
coup entre la PSU la page et un ensemble
de sujets que nous avons pu auditionner
aussi traiter moi-même ayant été
adjointe au maire petite enfance pendant
de très très très longues années avant
d'être vice-présidente de la protection
de l'enfance je connais ce que ça a pu
donner dans le cadre de ces financements
qui posent d'énormes soucis et qui
créent des immenses inégalités entre les
familles donc je crois que là nous
proposons une piste de réflexion pour
changer bien évidemment le mode de
financement tout en accompagnant les
collectivités et les crèches
associatives et privées mais il faut que
on soit en capacité de proposer quelque
chose de nouveau et je crois que la
première des choses et ça me paraît
évident c'est que ce système a amené un
peu d'ailleurs dans le rapport dont vous
prendrez connaissance dans sa lecture à
un moment donné c'est évalué un peu
comme une T2A dans les hôpitaux et en
fait il faut vraiment que tout ça change
pour que ce soit plus plus adapté en
fait aux familles et non pas avec un
système à l'heure qui pose des
problématiques nombreuses donc du coup
nous on propose plutôt des possibilités
sur des demi-journées quand les familles
doivent pouvoir s'absenter ou discuter
autour des problèmes de financement on
recommande y compris plusieurs choses
qui sont à l'échelle locale dans les
territoires que l'on puisse et l'État
devra évidemment
accompagner tous les dispositifs c'est
que nous a on des rames des relais
assistantes maternelles qui permettent
aussi aux gardes partagés donc à des
assistantes maternelles non agré de
venir avec les enfants on a parlé donc
de la formation le congé donc je vous en
ai parlé nous parlons bien évidemment
aussi sur la base d'un référentiel avec
la capacité d'avoir un label qualité qui
a été qui serait évidemment dans un
référentiel national et qui permettrait
d'avoir voir quelque chose qui soit plus
dans la qualité et le contrôle bien
évidemment Michel en a parlé tout à
l'heure nous recommandons que les
structures qui sont dans l'ensemble de
nos territoires quel qu'ell soit à
l'échelle d'une commune bénéficie d'un
conseil de crèche ça existe déjà dans de
nombreuses crèches municipales
départementales ou autres il y a des
exemples de bonnes pratiques ces
conseils de crèche doivent exister dorén
avant on le souhaite partout et donc
dans chaque structure pour être en lien
avec la vie professionnelle des
professionnels les parents et aussi la
structure à l'échelle du territoire qui
en général dispose avec
ce ce fonctionnement de crèche avant que
les parents deviennent un jour délégués
de parents d'élèves en maternel ou en
premier degré comme on dit et bien qu'il
y ait déjà cette capacité de l'échange
du dialogue avec l'intérêt toujours de
l'enfant de porter des projets ensemble
nous avons parmi les projets nous avons
aussi demander ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure un peu le diagnostic précoce et
le repérage sur un ensemble de sujets
donc que ce soit le diagnostic précoce
sur les enfants autour de 18 mois entre
15 et 18 mois pour les troubles
autistiques nous souhaitons évidemment
le repérage des familles les plus
fragiles pour pouvoir les accompagner
dans leur parentalité s'il y a des
problématiques idem sur le la la
possibilité bien sûr de dans le repérage
de l'enfance en danger et ça nous devons
pour cela avoir des personnel
extrêmement bien formé pour pouvoir
travailler cette question de manière
importante et euh nous avons aussi euh
donc euh fait plusieurs
préconisations qui sont euh sur les taux
d'encadrement donc que Michel a pu euh
vous pas vous évoquer et on redonner du
sens au métier ça c'est bien évidemment
le cœur de l'action le label qualité on
en a parlé mais on souhaite aussi que
les entreprises se lancent dans une
réflexion certaines le font mais on
aimerait discuter vraiment pour avoir un
label parentalité à l'intérieur en tout
cas une quelqu label ou autre chose
parce que ça peut s'appeler de
différentes manières mais on souhaite
vraiment que la parentalité d'un parent
d'un jeune enfant soit dans l'entreprise
quelque chose qui soit aussi porté de
manière forte je pense que dans le cadre
des travaux avec les organisations
syndicales le
ce sont des choses qui sont tout à fait
possibles pour certaines qui existent
comme parfois d'ailleurs dans des
conventions collectives il y a des mois
supplémentaires un mois supplémentaire
pour certains congés donc dans cette
disparité des dispositifs nous on
souhaite vraiment que les entreprises
s'engage sur ces questions et qu'elles
accompagnent les jeunes parents ça
permet aussi de fidéliser bien sûr les
gens qui travailleille dans l'entreprise
auprès de vous donc je pense que
l'ensemble des dispositifs pro opposés
répondent à cette attente ils ils
irriguent un nombre de sujets importants
parce que nous avons voulu l'inscrire
dans un plan global de la petite enfance
nous souhaitons redonner aussi une
vision un peu nationale aujourd'hui il y
a beaucoup de choses qui sont annoncées
mais elle ne donne pas de vision globale
de la politique publique de la petite
enfance en France c'est nécessaire
aujourd'hui de d'avoir cette référence
nationale avec un portage y compris nous
avons évoqué nous avons été assez loin
dans nos préconisations mais nous avons
aussi dit qu'il y avait plusieurs
ministères qui portent la question de
l'enfance et qu'au fond c'est pas que ça
trouble parce que chacun à
sa sa marque de dans son engagement et
que tout le monde n'est pas sur la même
politique publique mais en fait en la
décloisonnant à chaque fois on on la
rend moins lisible et nous on a besoin
de lisibilité parce que les concitoyens
attendent de nous tous des avancées en
matière de petite enfance je le redis
les besoins fondamentaux montrent à T
tous l'obligation absolue que nous avons
d'accompagner le mieux possible les
familles dans la parentalité et en
particulier de prendre soin des enfants
qui sont confiés et donc dans les
modèles qui sont aujourd'hui en pratique
nous avons besoin d'avoir dans les
recommandations à travers ces un peu
plus de 50 recommandations il y a
vraiment possibilité je crois d'engager
un plan global et une vision globale de
la partager y compris avec les ministère
pour que ça avance que ça avance vite et
que ça puisse avancer y compris très
vite dans nos territoires mais
l'engagement qui est le notre c'est de
suivre nos recommandations et de voir
comment tout ça va
avancer merci beaucoup mesdames les
rapporteurs je vais vous proposer un un
premier tour de table j'ai madame Sophie
rante qui m'a indiqué vouloir prendre la
parole oui merci madame la Présidente
mesames les rapporteurs merci beaucoup
pour ce ce rapport cette mission flash
tant ascendue hein puisquelle est on en
entend beaucoup parler on fait beaucoup
de visitees hein vous le savez comme
vous hein dans nos territoires euh
plusieurs sujets euh vous les avez
évoqué j'aurais peut-être aimé avoir
plutôt plus de détails euh sur l'équité
l'égalité des chances dans nos
territoires parce qu'en fait c'est aussi
ça qui nous occupe et nous préoccupe
certains territoires s'en sortent mieux
que d'autres certains ont plus
d'innovation que d'autres certains ont
plus de moyens aussi que d'autres et là
il y a vraiment cette question euh des
moyens que nous mettons dans tous les
territoires vous l'avez évoqué vous
n'avez pas pu évidemment puisque le
temps vous a été compté aller jusqu'au
territoire d'outremè donc ça c'est vrai
que c'est sur tous les territoires il y
a un vrai travail immense moi je partage
votre ambition et votre envie d'avoir
vraiment une vision globale qui remette
tout à plat en fait puisque'en fait il
nous manque quand même cette base de
savoir ce que nous voulons vraiment pour
notre accueil de la petite enfance moi
j'avais une question sur
l'uniformisation des critères euh sur
les lieux d'accueil il moi j'entends
beaucoup aujourd'hui de questionnement
par les différentes structures sur les
contrôles effectués par la PMI avant
ouverture vous l'avez dit sur le
bâtimentaire avec des contradictions
avec des incohérences c'est-à-dire il y
a des choses qui sont interdites à un
endroit autorisé à d'autres comprend pas
bien en fait comment sont élaborés les
critères de ce que nous attendons dans
l'accueil là je parle vraiment sur les
espaces les mètres carrés mais les
personnels aussi en fait he tout est
quand même assez peu uniformisé donc on
il y a une un tiraillement une un un
ressentiment quand même he des équipes
qui comprennent pas pourquoi il y a
plusieurs préconisations de données vous
l'avez dit aussi sur la manière dont on
contrôle les établissements avec plus de
dialogue et vraiment une autre manière
de se considérer de se parler dans ce
domainelà où ça ne ressemble pas à un
contrôle je dirais allez de de police ou
gendarmerie euh c'est pas le c'est pas
ce sujet-là qui nous préoccupe et
franchement là ça doit vraiment euh se
transformer donc un grand merci euh
peut-être des des des précisions
là-dessus et puis vous avez évoqué le
benchmark c'est-à-dire comment font les
autres euh on est moins bon que les
autres mais on est peut-être meilleur
aussi dans certains domaines vous avez
évoqué aussi les innovations les choses
qu' se qui se font bien c'est-à-dire les
territoires euh qui ont des choses à
nous dire et je pense que ça ça pourrait
faire partie aussi vous l'avez évoqué
sur la haute savoir euh peut-être il y
a-t-il d'autres territoires où il se
passent des choses bien ce serait bien
aussi peut-être qu'on en parle merci
beaucoup en tout cas pour votre
travail pardon merci Madame rank vous
voulez la
parole merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames les
rapporteurs chers collègues tout d'abord
merci merci effectivement pour ce
travail qui réflète tout à fait les
revendications et les recommandations
qui ont été portées pendant des années
par les professionnel de la petite
enfance également mis en évidence par le
récent le récent rapport de Li euh la
question qui se pose à la lecture donc
de votre rapport c'est maintenant qu'en
est-il et qu'est-ce que nous pouvons
faire concrètement pour effectivement
refonder
complètement ce ce mode ces modes
d'accueil comment on peut rendre cela
effectif est-ce qu'il a une rencontre
avec Madame Aurore berger est-elle prévu
et parce que je pense par exemple aux
recommandations en matière de contrôle
qui paraissent tout à fait juste mais en
réalité aujourd'hui nous n'avons
toujours pas l'arrêté qui prévoit une
obligation de contrôle annuelle pour
l'ensemble des établissements d'accueil
du jeunes enfant et qui est attendu
depuis 2007 par ailleurs je m'interroge
sur le nouveau rôle d'évaluation
qualitative des structures pour la PMI
et donc l'externalisation des contrôles
des bâtiments quelles seraient vos
recommandations pour renforcer cette
nouvelle évaluation et donc la
communication entre la structure et la
PMI vous avez soulever également le rôle
à jouer de la CAF actuellement
expérimenté en de
savoir euh donc ce sera un modèle que
vous souhaiteriez porter dans l'ensemble
de nos structures et nos départements et
enfin vous avez en préambule évoqué la
volonté votre volonté de réduire
progressivement l'emploi des
professionnels non diplômés et non
qualifié est-ce que en soi on doit
comprendre que vous êtes favorable à
l'abrogation de l'arrêté du 22 juillet
2022 je vous
remercie merci beaucoup juste dans le
mon intervention euh en préambule euh
j'ai indiqué que Madame berger euh
viendrait la semaine pre prochaine mardi
prochain à 17h normalement enfin juste
après lesqag pour justement nous
répondre sur ce sujet là donc c'est une
première réponse maintenant je laisse la
parole à Monsieur
Martinet merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames les rapporteurs merci pour ce
travail conséquent en un temps limité
écoutez mon intervention consiste a à
souligner un certain nombre et
d'ailleurs ils sont nombreux points
d'accord que ce soit sur le constat ou
les recommandations en matière de petite
enfance j'insisterai aussi sur un point
de désaccord précis mais ferme sur le
crédit d'impôt famille et j'évoquerai à
la fin ce qui me semble un manque une
absence le sujet de la marchandisation
de la petite enfance des acteurs privés
lucratifs des dérives spécifique à ce
secteur qui sont vraiment à peine
survolés dans ce rapport donc vous nous
direz si c'est volontaire ou non après
tout en quelques semaines on peut pas
aborder tous les sujets mais comme vous
le savez moi je suis l'auteur d'une
demande de commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur ce sujet du business
des crèches privées lucratives cette
commission d'enquête parlementaire elle
sera l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale la semaine du 27 novembre et
j'espère que ici on sera nombreux à être
présent à voter favorablement pour
lancer cette commission d'enquête et
surtout qu'on qu'on profitera de la
commission d'enquête de ses moyens
d'investigation dans les dans les mois à
venir pour travailler tous ensemble et
aller au bout de ce sujet sujet des
dérives du secteur privé lucratif parce
qu'encore une fois je crois que pour nos
enfants c'est important que ce sujet
soit soit investigué sérieusement par la
représentation nationale bon concernant
je reviens à mon premier point qui est
le les points d'accord je pense qu'avec
ce rapport vous arrivez à soulever une
une chose très importante si le secteur
de la petite enfance est dans une crise
aussi importante c'est parce qu'en fait
il y a une contradiction entre d'un côté
une prise de conscience notamment grâce
aux travauxci fique de l'importance de
la complexité des besoins des jeunes
enfants qui sont pas seulement des
questions alimentaires sanitaires mais
qui sont bien plus larges que ça qui
sont affectifs qui relève du du
développement cognitif donc il y a dans
la société une prise de conscience très
importante des besoins des jeunes
enfants mais en même temps le secteur de
la petite enfance qui est censé répondre
à ses besoins il est dans un moment
d'effondrement où il a rarement été
aussi affaibli et rarement aussi peu en
capacité de répondre à ses besoins donc
c'est cette tension qui fait que le
secteur est en crise et que tant mieux
les politiques s'en mèlent les M mdias
s' mê les les parents sont préoccupés
par ces par ces questions vous dressez
des des pistes de de recommandations qui
me paraissent pertinentes évidemment
j'aurai pas le temps de toutes les
aborder je reviens sur une vous dites il
faut arrêter avec la logique de
déréglementation du secteur mais vous
avez 1LE fois raison oui parce que cette
logique de déréglementation elle a été
pensée comme une réponse à la crise on
narrive pas à recruter alors on
déréglemente alors qu'en fait elle a été
à la source de la crise qu'elle
l'aggravé donc effectivement cette
dérèglementation a commencé au moins en
2010 avec la ministre Morano bon ça
madame Santiago vous connaissez ce sujet
mieux que moi mais je me permets de dire
que la déréglementation elle a
continuuer jusqu'à il y a pas si
longtemps que ça jusqu'à l'été dernier
avec un décret qui a été pris par le
gouvernement et qui entre autres choses
permet le recrutement de personnel non
qualifiés au sein des établissements
d'accueil des jeunes enfants donc je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose qu'on
ait un rapport qui nous dise maintenant
on arrête avec cette logique de
déglementation mais que au contraire il
faut renforcer les normes renforcer les
exigences en terme de qualification en
terme d'encadrement et cetera sur ce
sujet de comment on renforce la la
réglementation je peux pas m'empêcher de
de souligner un point important la
question euh de la suroccupation des
établissements à 115 %. parce que je
dois avouer une faiblesse j'ai essayé
pendant le projet de loi plein emploi en
déposant un amendement pour interdire la
suroccupation à 115 % j'ai essayé de
convaincre je n'ai pas réussi à
convaincre la majorité qui a rejeté mon
mon amendement du coup j'espère que ce
rapport les arguments que vous avez mis
seront plus efficaces et que la
prochaine fois que à l'Assemblée
nationale on aura à discuter d'un
amendement qui dit des choses simples
hein juste pas plus de 100 % des enfants
dans les crèches que ce soit adopté
largement en tout cas j'espère qu'on
arrivera de ce point de vue à faire à
faire bouger les lignes toujours sur les
points d'accord je vais très vite dessus
vous vous insister évidemment sur la
formation sur le recrutement des
professionnels sur leur leur carrière on
le dira jamais assez on peut pas
construire de service public de la
petite enfance si on a pas des
professionnels de la petite enfance
parmi tous les sujets que vous avez
abordé alors j'ai l'impression que à
l'oral vous y avez plus insister que
alécrit dans le rapport il y a la
question des rémunérations il y a la
question des salaires il faut payer plus
et mieux les professionnels de la petite
enfance voilà dans un secteur où elles
sont pour la plupart pays auosmic ou
même quand elles ont un bac + 3 ou un
bac + 4 elles sont quelques dizaines
d'euros au dessus du SMIC quand elles
sont recrutées on ne s'en sortira pas
s'il y a pas un choc d'attractivité une
augmentation des salaires mais tant
mieux si on est d'accord sur ce point et
si là aussi on pourra le défendre
ensemble je je viens du coup euh au
point de désaccord euh parce qu'on a sur
le crédit d'impôt famille vous proposez
dans le rapport de mieux communiquer de
le développer de de l'étendre ce crédit
d'impôt famille moi j'y suis
particulièrement opposé c'est une niche
fiscale c'est une niche fiscale qui a
été le moteur cette dernière décennie du
développement du secteur privé lucratif
parce que avec ce crédit d'impôt famille
c'est pas seulement 50 % des dépenses
d'une entreprises qui sont remboursées
en crédit d'impôt il faut rajouter 25 %
de frais qui sont déductibles donc ça
veut dire dire Queen fait quand une
entreprise et généralement c'est des
grandes entreprises achètent un berceau
dans une crèche privée lucrative il y a
les 75 % qui sont payé par l'État c'est
pour ça que je parle de niche de niche
fiscale et ça a un effet inflationniste
parce qu'on voit que comme par hasard
c'est berceau dans le privé lucratif qui
sont payés grâce au crédit d'impôt
famille bah c'est aussi ceux qui coûtent
le plus cher parce que fort logiquement
l'entreprise elle en paye que 25 % donc
elle est pas très préoccupé de quel est
le prix au Bero et ça fait des prix qui
sont extrêmement élevés qui sont de
l'ordre de 14000 15000 16000 € BO qui a
un prix qui est très qui est très élevé
donc je pense que au contraire on a un
problème sur le sujet du crédit d'impôt
au famille que c'est des moyens qui
devraient être réorienté il s'agit pas
évidemment de réduire les moyens pour le
secteur de la petite enfance mais c'est
des moyens qui devraient être réorientés
vers des acteurs publics ou ou
associatif et que en tout cas il faut
trouver un moyen si ce n'est de faire
disparaître en tout cas de raboter cette
niche cette niche fiscale et donc je
finis sur le dernier point je disais le
crédit d'impôt famille on fait un peu la
la transition la question du secteur
privé lucratif bon il s'agit pas là pour
moi de donner tous les arguments pour ma
commission d'enquête mais mais
j'aimerais quand même que tout le monde
prenne conscience euh du grave problème
qui s'est constitué ces dernières années
donc non seulement par le développement
du secteur privé lucratif mais aussi et
surtout par la concentration de ce
secteur dans quelques entreprises de
crèche vous savez que c'est quatre
entreprises qui détiennent les 2/ers des
places de crèche dans le privé lucratif
et ces entreprises elles sont toutes
liées directement ou indirectement à des
fonds d'investissement qui ont considéré
que le secteur de la petite enfance
c'était un lieu d'investissement et de
rentabilité qui était particulièrement
profitable quand on décrit tout ça
excusez-moi mais le parallèle avec ce
qui s'est passé dans les épates privés
Orpa et corient saute aux yeux voilà on
a un sujet sur un secteur que ce soit
les personnes âgées ou la petite enfance
qui ne devraiit pas être exposé à la
recherche de profit à la recherche de
rentabilité parce que sinon ça crée de
graves problèmes parce que on peut pas à
la fois additionner la vulnérabilité des
publics euh comme comme les jeunes
enfants avec la recherche de profit les
deux ça fait un cocktail explosif des
publics vulnérables et de la recherche
de profit ça fait des dérives et
malheureusement c'est ce qu'on rencontre
dans le privé lucratif donc encore une
fois j'espère qu'on pourra se retrouver
pour voter favorablement au lancement de
cette commission d'enquête et que on
pourra travailler
ensemble à empêcher ces dérives il en va
de l'intérêt des des jeunes enfants j'en
suis convaincu je vous remercie merci
beaucoup pour ce premier tour de table
avant de me vous poser quelques
questions déjà chacun fera en son amé
conscience pour la commission
d'enquête pour ma part euh le sujet
privé lucratif est en partie traité déjà
dans cette dans ce rapport je sais pas
si vous avez le temps de le lire depuis
hier et je comprends que vous AZ pas eu
le temps parce qu'on l'a eu tard et je
m'en excuse mais en tous les cas il y a
quand même une partie qui est traitée
vous faites la comparatif avec les
éepads et ce qui avait été dit la grande
différence entre le moment où le
scandale les éepad est sorti et ici
c'est que les livres sur les crèches
quand ils sont sortis le rapport IGAS
était déjà sorti depuis plus de 6 mois
donc on avait déjà à les donnés ce qui
ce qui n'est quand même pas la même
chose donc aujourd'hui refaire une
commission d'enquête pour aller sur la
même chose que ce que nos collègues sont
en train de faire c'est un choix elles
l'ont fait liigas l'a fait ça nous fera
perdre encore je pense du temps je pense
qu'on ferait mieux d'être tous ensemble
pour essayer de pousser un nombre de
préconisations qui sont dedans sur
lequel on se retrouve et effectivement
je je pense qu'on a un certain nombre de
préconisations sur les quel on se
retrouve et qu'il faudrait pousser et je
pense qu'il vaudrait mieux euh peut-être
trouver ce qui a besoin de bouger au
niveau législatif essayer de le pousser
plutôt que d'aller vers une enè
commission d'enquête qui va revenir sur
ce qu'on sait déjà entre Ligas ce qu'on
vient de faire là et qui aura peut-être
juste pour but de faire un acte
politique et et de la vidéo mais en tout
cas moi je pense qu'il y a urgence à
aller plus vite et je trouve que ce
qu'il y a dans ce rapport est plutôt
intéressant donc engageons-nous plutôt à
aller plus rapidement sur euh une
j'allais dire une une évolution du
secteur moi je suis prête à ce qu'on
regarde effectivement peut-être un texte
porté par la délégation s'il y a des
modifications législatives à avoir avec
vous sur la base de de ce rapport moi
j'avais quelques questions mesdames euh
voilà j'ai pas bien compris euh sur les
Mames les maisons d'assistante
maternelle j'ai pas bien compris parce
que dans le rapport vous parlez d'un
lieu de rencontre de professionnels euh
parce que moi ah c'est une coquille
parce que ah c'est le RAM parce que pour
moi les Mames une coquille euh parce que
pour moi les maisons d'assistance
maternelle c'est plusieursances
maternelles qui se mettent ensemble euh
donc ok on est d'accord
là-dessus très bien sur la micro crèche
euh vous en avez parlé donc là on est
complètement dans la partie privée les
micro crèches on sait qu'effectivement
c'est ce qui a été notamment beaucoup
développé dans les petites collectivités
pour avoir un système de de de garde à
proposer donc par comment on pourrait
faire pour essayer d'aller là-dessus et
vous parlez du problème d'avoir obtenu
de ne pas avoir de diplôme d'état pour
être référent mais j'ai pas vu de
préconisation le demandant donc est-ce
que vous avez prévu euh de de le mettre
et euh en tout cas la dernière question
que j'avais c'était sur le label qualité
par qui verriez-vous sa délivrance voilà
je vous
remercie
je vais commencer par répondre à ma
collègue Sophie errante ensuite madame
rank qui ont posé à peu près les mêmes
questions Sophie erante sur l'égalité
des des
territoires et sur l'uniformisation le
référentiel il existe déjà un référen je
crois que était sur le départ il existe
déjà un
référentiel qui qui qui existe mais
voilà il faut il faut faire une mission
d'évaluation forcément on a eu comm moi
euh ça c'est donc sur cette partie- làà
mais de toute façon nous ce que nous
voulons infiner euh suite à à ce rapport
à cette mission
c'est
l'égalité l'équité
l'égalité sur tous les territoires j'ai
l'impression de me répéter
suite à mon rapport sur la PMI parce que
effectivement c'est c'est le sujet que
l'égalité et l'équité
ensuite concernant les contrôles PMI ils
existent j'allais dire depuis toujours
mais suite à mon suite à mon rapport sur
la PMI vous avez pu constater si vous
avez lu ne serait-ce que la la synthèse
qu'effectivement pourquoi un un contrôle
qui doit avoir lieu lie annuellement
n'est pas effectué euh évidemment il
manque de ressources humaines parce que
la PMI euh euh est appelé à d'autres
tâches le halz vert le bilan de santé en
école maternelle enfin ça c'est leur
cœur de métier et le contrôle évaluation
alors je suis d'accord avec C ce mot de
contrôle hormis le le contrôle et la re
le réagrément tous les 5 ans pour les
assistantes maternelles et tous les 3
ans c'est ça pour euh j'ai de je j'ai un
j'ai j'ai j'ai un trop de mémoire pour
les lieux d'accueil
euh collectif collectif c'est tous les 3
ans ou tous les 5 ans aussi non c'est
tous les 3 ans c'est les 3 ans hein
voilà je des fois je j'intervertis tous
les 3 ans pour euh ils n'ont lieu
principalement que tous les 3 ans ou
tous les 5 ans pour les assiantes
maternelles parce que ça aussi c'est un
un lieu d'accueil euh c'est pas une
crèche mais c'est un lieu d'accueil
c'est c'est pas le même mais euh c'est
le plus le plus pris le Pr pris en
compte par par nos familles et bien le
le la solution vient de faire donc soit
embaucher embaucher encore embauché
c'est pour ça qu'il faut mettre
évidemment ce que j'ai dit au retour de
du rapport PMI beaucoup plus de de fonds
euh dans dans la PMI pour que euh on
puisse avoir ces ces C ces visites je
veux pas appeler contrôle tous les ans
parce que c'est écrit dans la loi c'est
écrit dans la loi enfin tous les ans
pour les pour les assistantes
maternelles mais également tous les ans
aussi pour les lieux d'accueil collectif
il faut absolument qu'on enlève on
enlève du des des des missions qui leur
ont été données donc je parle au au aux
professionnels de la PMI durant ces 20
dernières années c'est allé et on n pas
mis plus de moyens malheureusement c'est
pour ça que nous en sommes venus à une
PMI pratiquement exang au moment de mon
rapport et euh qui va peut-être un peu
mieux sur certains territoires parce qu'
évidemment comme comme on parle souvent
de ce qui est bien fait dans certains
territoires on voudrait le le l'étendre
sur le plan national euh mais voilà il
faut il faut pousser sans arrêt dire ben
voilà dans ce département il se passe
des choses merveilleuses euh au profit
de nos enfants petits petits ou grands
il faudrait il faudrait y aller et puis
faire évidemment ces bonnes pratiques
qu'ell soit sur tout tout le tout tout
le pays toute tout le territoire mais
malheureusement euh il faut du temps a
temp et vous savez que comme moi que
pour faire avancer les choses des fois
il faut pousser et avec Isabelle de
toute façon on va pousserin de toute
façon
euh ça c'est c'est le mot d'ordre dès le
début
ensuite la bne les bonnes pratiques de
coopération entre la PMI et et la CAF en
ce moment même euh donc c'était sur le
territoire de Haute Savoie il y a
d'autres territoires il y a d'autres
département ça ça se passe très bien et
nous le demandons je sais pas si vous
étiez là
euh quand est-ce que vous êtes arrivé
madame rank mais euh nous le demandons
nous le préconisons nous demandons à ce
qu'il ça soit étendu sur tout le
territoire
national tout le territoire ça
enlèvera la charge de travail aux au aux
infirmières puricultrices puisquen fait
c'est elles qui font le travail au sein
de la PMI et ça leur laera plus de temps
pour être au cœur de vraiment de leur
métier auprès des auprès des enfants et
en en apport aux professionnels qui qui
œuvre dans dans les crèches dans les
lieux d'accueil
ensuite je vous parler du SI
FAM vous voulez pas m'écouter sur le si
FEM cher collègue après tout le reste
c'est ma collègue qui va qui va vous
alors le le si FEM évidemment que nous
nous associ nous associons cette
extension à à beaucoup plus de
transparence dans le rapport vous le
verrez il faut vous avez pas eu le temps
de le lire je le
sais complètement laommation 51 dit plus
voilà voilà et même et même également
l'utilisation des fonds publics pour
l'ouverture des des structures privées
donc beaucoup plus de transparence et
nous comptons vraiment œuvrer pour que
cela se fasse et cela soit voilà c'est
tout ce que j'ai à vous dire sur le si
FEM maintenant je laisse la parole à ma
collègue beaucoup de
questions globalement je je réponds
comme ça si des fois j'ai oublié une
réponse n'hésitez pas quelque chose que
je naurait pas aborder euh en fait sur
vous avez dit tout à l'heure chers
collègues équité égalité en fait je
crois que dans ce rapport on montre que
si on a une vision globale et un portage
national global de la petite enfance euh
dans cette dans ce changement de
paradigme en fait ça permet
euh d'amener tout le monde y compris
bien sûr les collectivités qui sont des
acteurs très importants et qui font
beaucoup euh pour la petite enfance dans
leur communes d'étayer avec les bonnes
pratiques et de lutter contre les
inégalités par les bonnes pratiques
puisque du coup nos territoires sont
évidemment complètement différents entre
le territoire urbain périurbain rural
les questions ne sont pas les même mais
nous l'avons vu dans les auditions
Michel avait pu le voir aussi dans son
autre rapport sur la PMI il y a plein
compris en milieu rural de très bonnes
pratiques qui se font avec des bus enfin
de petites choses assez bien pensé
autour de la petite enfance et c'est ces
modèles là en fait et c'est parce qu'on
manque de vision globale que nous
n'avons pas la capacité aujourd'hui à
part dans le cadre d'audition et et donc
d'avoir ou ou de d'élus qui sont sur le
terrain dans leur territoire et qui
connaissent ses bons exemples et ses
bonnes pratiques on a besoin en fait que
ce soit plus coordonné mieux diffusé au
territoire qui lui cherche un moyen de
mettre en place quelque chose et dont il
n'a pas totalement la mesure donc en
tout cas en partie sur l'égalité et
l'équité je crois que la
diffusion massive des bonnes pratiques à
l'échelle de quelque chose qui est non
pas centralisé mais qui est une
politique globale de l'enfance donne
cette capacité à irriguer avec tous les
services qui correspondent à une
politique de la petite enfance de
pouvoir dans les
territoires être en capacité d'avoir le
travail qui est fait avec en général je
vous ai dit les collectivités et en
particulier les maires quand ils sont
sur cette politique publique qui est
menée de manière assez forte sur les
conseils euh je voulais vous donner des
exemples de bonnes pratiques y compris
dans ce qu'on évoquait à travers non pas
le contrôle mais le partage avec les
familles de là aussi de ce cercle
vertueux autour de l'enfant et de
l'organisation les exemples on a
l'exemple du conseil de crèche qui me
semble être un excellent modèle et c'est
pour ça qu'on propose que ce conseil de
crèche se fasse dans toutes les crèches
aujourd'hui il existe de
manière oui à l'échelle de territoire à
l'échelle de de de trois municipalités
peut-être pas la 4e donc en fait c'est
tout à fait en effet comme vous
l'évoquez tout à l'heure cette équité
cette égalité sous une forme de
politique un peu globale elle n'est pas
forcément portée par contre ça existe ça
existe de manière massive he aujourd'hui
les conseillers de crèche et ça je crois
que c'est l'essentiel et moi on l'a
écrit comme ça après je ne sais pas si
ce sera porté de cette manière là mais
nous on le souhaite on a écrit
obligation pour tout le monde qu'on soit
une petite structure ou une plus grande
structure qu'elle soit municipale mais
là c'est moins le cas municipal quasi
ils ont tous des conseils de crèche mais
pour les crèches et en particulier sur
les crèches qui sont les petites les
petites crèches les mini crèches les
questions crèche parfois associatives
crèche évidemment privée lucrative le
conseil de crèche n'existe pas partout
il y en a qui le font pas beaucoup il me
semble en tout cas on n' pas une vision
globale mais il est évident que si déjà
on avait les parents dans ces conseils
de crèche avec un lien de d'échange qui
se fait sur les bonnes pratiques de la
crèche dans la structure coordonnée à
l'échelle du territoire avec l'élu de
secteur en général euh franchement je
vous le dis il y aurait certainement
beaucoup moins de possibilités de passer
à travers les maills du contrôle parce
que le contrôle il se fait aussi par le
dialogue avec tout le monde et de
trouver des solutions ensemble donc moi
je crois en tout cas beaucoup à la vertu
de ce conseil de crèche qui associe un
ensemble d'acteurs dans la crèche dans
la structure pour l'enfant et ensuite à
l'échelle du territoire avec les
responsables de la PMI les élus de
secteur et là je vous assure que le
dialogue d'une île secret il se fait et
que s'il y a des remontées
d'informations qui ne vont pas vous
pouvez déclencher tous les contrôles
possibles et évidemment qui vont dans le
bon sens sur le fait que dans notre
rapport il y ait peu de il a été évoqué
peu de rapport sur les crèches
privées en fait je pense que dans ce
rapport on dit très clairement par une
politique très renforcée dans de
nombreux sujets que justement on répond
à cette difficulté que nous avons
évidemment perçu et qui est écrite dans
le rapport donc peut-être que à la
lecture de vos yeux elle n'a pas été
assez rédigée mais en tout cas pour nous
elle nous est apparu bien évidemment que
quand on renforce le contrôle dans les
structures par le personnel mieux formé
quand on dit qu'on ne peut pas
déréglementer le secteur avec le
surbooking dans les crèches quand on dit
très clairement qu'une crèche
d'entreprise qui qui qu'une crèche
privée lucrative a un berceau réservé
entreprise en attendant d'avoir cet
enfant en général elle prend une famille
de manière temporaire contraire aux
intérêts de l'enfant bien évidemment et
à ses besoins fondamentaux parce qu'au
moment où l'entreprise dit bah j'ai
besoin du berceau que j'avais réservé le
bébé ça se trouve ça ne fait que 3 mois
qu'il est là et on dit à la famille vous
n'avait plus la place c'est l'entreprise
et donc un nouvel enfant qui aura la
place on l'interdit je veux dire Franch
franchement on a été très loin dans
l'approche des problématiques et de la
déréglementation donc je crois qu'avec
les préconisations qu'on fait on englobe
l'ensemble de la politique petite
enfance et les problèmes qui ont été
posés y compris ce des crèches privé
lucratif que vous avez cité donc du coup
je suis assez surprise mais je je peux
l'entendre parce que les lectures
évidemment la communication fait que les
lectures peuvent être différentes mais
vraiment on est extrêmement on va très
très loin dans nos préconisations sur
ces sujetsl et croyez-moi que c'est pas
si simple pour ceux qui vont le lire et
qui vont se demander comment ils vont le
mettre en place après sur le
label euh aujourd'hui le label je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui serait en
tout cas tout d'abord il faudrait qu'il
y ait un référentiel donc ça je pense
que c'est pas très difficile à faire
parce que des labels il y en a déjà
nous-même moi pour si je prends mon
exemple dans ma vie d'élu local euh nous
avions déjà des labels donc ils existent
donc je crois que ces labels comme ils
existent ça peut être rapide de faire un
label un une forme de ce label qui
deviendrait national et je pense que
peut-être que la référence ce sera aussi
ben en fait ce service public de la
petite enfance qu'on attend de manière
nationale de manière globale ou alors il
sera mis en place peut-être par les PMI
si c'était autre autrement que c'est
organisé mais en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut une référence
claire identifiée pour ce label par
contre je suis certaine que ce label
peut être mis en place très rapidement
et qui le permettrait non pas d'être
donné à tout le monde mais de rentrer
bien dans les dans les critères du label
pour le pour l'avir je pense que là
aussi c'est un une garantie pour les
familles de quelque chose quand devant
une crèche vous avez un label qui n vous
a pas été donné juste comme ça pour
faire joli devant la porte mais qui
indique des bonnes manières de travail
d'accompagner les enfants tant sur le
bâti on en parle souvent mais aussi sur
la qualité bien évidemment et sûrement
de la prise en charge et de
l'accompagnement de l'enfant dans ses
besoins
fondamentaux je crois que pour les
parents c'est quand même assez rassurant
ce genre de de pratique donc voilà c'est
des choses qui ne demandent pas de
révision législative et qui peuvent se
faire et je crois que dans ce qu'on
propose il y a des choses qui relèvent
du législatif mais beaucoup ou peuvent
se mettre en place d'ors et déjà et nous
on vous nous avez posé toujours tout à
l'heure la question mais ma collègue est
partie on nous avons rencontré la
ministre hier nous lui avons fait part
de nos ouais de nos préconisations et en
fait de toute façon dans l'absolu on
l'auditionne comme l'a dit madame la
Présidente la semaine prochaine mais
dans les auditions nous l' nous l'avons
rencontré hier pour lui parler de nos
préconisation merci beaucoup si à peu
près c'est tout bon euh moi je trouve
qu'il y a une dépréconisation aussi qui
va dans le sens d'arrêter cette
marchandisation c'est le fait qu'il a
deux effectifs minimum par
établissement qui est pour le secteur
privé mais qui vaut pour aussi
malheureusement d'autres qu'on pu qu'on
peut voir où il est assez facile de
mettre une personne le matin à
l'ouverture et je pense que ça ça serait
une vraie révolution que soit publ ou
privé madame erand vouliez je crois
reprendre la parole oui merci juste par
rapport à au aux précisions vous disiez
sur les contrôles ou en tout cas les les
conditions d'accueil là où il y a des
disparités alors après je reveris je je
rencontrerai de nouveau les personnes
que j'ai déjà rencontré suite à votre
rapport c'est vraiment qu'est-ce qu'on
attend d'un lieu d'accueil en fait et
que ce soit bien carré et précis et que
les mêmes règles soient pour tout le
monde les mêmes c'est ça en fait he qui
est l'essentiel peut-être que les
référentiels existent en tout cas la
mise en œuvre elle est comp complex et
beaucoup plus éloigné de ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer comme étant idéal
voilà parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens se
parlent et les réseaux se parlent donc
forcément les parents échangent entre
moi j'ai le droit à ça toi tu as pas
droit à ça moi ma crèche est comme ça et
et voilà vous voyez bien quels sont les
échanges qu'on peut avoir moi j'avais
une question un peu plus précise sur les
conseils de crèche là où je voulais
revenir sur à quel étage à quel niveau
doit-il se tenir pour les rencontres que
j'ai pu avoir ayant été maèire aussi
d'une petite commune
moi j'avais créé le projet éducatif
local c'est aussi un lieu de débat
interne à un conseil municipal et les
crèches qui
viennent sur un territoire si elles sont
privées ou si elles sont publque c'est
pas tout à fait la même puisque le maire
moi j'ai j'avais tout rendu public donc
effectivement le dialogue vous l'avez en
interne puisque ce sont vos salariés et
votre responsabilité là vous avez une
crèche qui vient s'installer sur votre
territoire qui est porté parfois par des
entreprises par effectivement des un un
réseau de de crèche là où ça devient
compliqué c'est que l'élu le maire est
au courant qu'il y a une ouverture peut
venir la visiter à l'ouverture mais ne
sait pas forcément ce qui s'y passe donc
en fait c'est comment est-ce que ce
conseil de crèche qui fonctionne puisque
moi j'ai rencontré aussi les parents qui
sont très satisfaits mais ça ne franchit
pas la barre de la crèche est-ce que
dans un projet éducatif local est-ce que
dans un dialogue avec les mun
municipalité et là je reviens à la
question il y a le Congrès des maires
qui arrive bientôt est-ce que ce débat
là est-ce que ces discussions là vont
être aussi à l'ordre du jour du conse du
du congrès des maires qui Arve merci
ouis monsieur Martinet pardon
oui merci madame la Présidente bon je je
vous confirme j'ai lu très attentivement
ce ce rapport j'ai fait ça ma tout à
l'heure pendant ma pause déjeuner et
c'était très instructif non plus
sérieusement sur la question du prévé
créatif qu'on se comprenne bien j'ai
bien conscience que dans ce rapport il y
a toute une série de préconisations qui
visent à davantage réguler les secteur
et qui de fait vont impacter ceux qui
tire le plus sur la corde et donc vont
impacter en priorité le privé lucratif
donc ça j'en ai conscience et c'est
quelque chose qu'on partage j'ai essayé
de le dire rapidement dans mon précédent
propos là où je dis que euh on va dire
ça n'a pas été creuser si je j'utilise
cette formule c'est sur la spécificité
du secteur privé lucratif au moins sur
deux choses l'utilisation de l'argent
public et la stratégie financière de ces
groupes sur l'utilisation de l'argent
public madame la Présidente Goulet vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure à la
différence des EPAD il y a eu un rapport
de Ligas qui fait que maintenant on sait
alors à mon tour de vous accuser de pas
lire complètement les rapports non je
plaisante le rapport de Ligas ce qui dit
sur l'utilisation de l'argent public
c'est qu'on on ne sait pas justement
Ligas dit on ne sait pas comment est
util utiliser l'argent public ils
pointent des stratégies ils disent il y
a des montages financiers à base de SCI
ça crée de l'opacité ils disent il y a
des frais de siège payés par les
établissements qui remontent au groupe
qu'on ne peut plus contrôler on ne sait
pas à quoi sert cet argent il y a de
l'augmentation de la dotation aux
amortissements c'est une alerte sur
comment utiliser l'argent public pour
peut-être se constituer un patrimoine
bref le Ligas pointe toute une série
d'alertes sur l'utilisation de l'argent
public alerte pour lequel je pense il y
a besoin d'enquêter d'où la la demande
de commission d'enquête l'autre point je
disais la spécificité du secteur privé
lucratif qui qui n'a pas été creusé dans
ce dans ce rapport et encore une fois je
pense que c'était impossible à faire
dans les délais et avec le pouvoir d'une
mission d'information les stratégie
financière est-ce que vous avez
auditionné Antin Tower Brook
infravia là ce que je viens de citer
c'est les fonds d'investissement qui
pèsent les 2/ers des berceaux en crèche
privé lucra vous vous avez vu la
Fédération française des entreprises de
crèche qui est le lobby des crèches
privées donc je je ne doute pas une
seule seconde que vous n'avez fait
preuve d'aucune naïveté quand vous avez
discuté avec eux c'est pas ça mon
accusation mais je dis juste vous avez
discuté avec le lobby vous avez pas
discuté avec les actionnaires et vous
n'avez pas pu leur poser des questions
comme par exemple quelle est votre
stratégie financière quand vous avez
racheté les petit chaperon rouge babyou
et cetera quel est le niveau de
rentabilité de profitabilité que vous
avez exiger quel est le PACT managérial
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle dans ce
secteur que vous avez fait avec les
dirigeants au moment où vous êtes devenu
actionnaire ça c'est des questions qui
sont essentielles parce que de ça
découle tout le reste si en haut vous
avez un fond d'investissement qui dit le
niveau de profitabilité ça doit être x %
en conséquence et à la fin jusqu'au
terrain sur qu'est-ce qu'on peut acheter
comment sont payés les professionnels
est-ce que elles sont assez nombreuses
ça a des conséquences qui sont
délétaires pour les pour les enfants
donc je pense que ces sujets-là il reste
à à à creuser et il faut qu'on le fasse
le plus vite possible parce que tant
qu'on n pas fait la lumière sur ces
stratégies financières qui
potentiellement sont extrêmement
défavorables à la qualité de l'accueil
des jeunes enfants tant qu'on n pas fait
la lumière là-dessus ça va continuer à
perdurer donc je le dis vraiment pas en
opposition avec vos rapport et vos
préconisations parce que encore une fois
je disais les les préconisations de
régulation de l'ensemble du secteur
elles seront favorables mais il y a une
question spécifique privée lucrative qui
je pense a a pas encore été
traitée merci beaucoup alors avant de
laisser la parole à mes collègues
monsieur Martinet vous faites
effectivement le choix voilà de la
polémique et de la publicité sur ces
crèches privées nous nous faisons le
choix de de l'action et de faire évoluer
rapidement la situation car comme vous
l'avz indiqué hein ce qui est proposé
dans ce dans ce rapport résoudrait pas
mal les choses une chose est sûre nous
sommes d'accord sur nos deux accords et
moi en tout cas j'espère faire évoluer
très vite la situation avec les
proposition qui sont dans ce rapport qui
résoudrait pas mal de choses et après il
se débrouilleraiit dans leur fond je
vous laisse la parole juste prendre la
parole puis Isabelle je suis sûr que tu
as beaucoup de choses à dire aussi juste
on n pas on n pas auditionné que le
lobby comme vous l'appelez la Fédération
je les connais depuis depuis la PMI vous
rendez compte et je savais à qui j'avais
à faire
mais les gens les gens à qui on
s'adresse j'évolu et je voulais les les
réentendre également Isabelle pour ce
rapport
là et je vous assure
que beaucoup beaucoup de choses on ont
changé j' j'avais les mêmes personne
pourend devant moi mais avec moins
d'aplom j'en dirais pas plus ensuite on
n pas on s'est pas satisfait que de la
Fédération française des établissements
de crèche on a
auditionné Bilou et les
autres donc on a auditionné les
professionnels les gestionnaires et on
l'a dit dans le rapport et les
professionnels qui travaillent au sein
de ces crèches donc ce que nous
préconisons ce que nous demandons ce que
nous nous obligeons même puisque nous
demandons obligatoirement que
euh ça comme disait madame la Présidente
euh ça va impacter
croyez-moi que ça fait parler comme on
dit communément dans les chaumières
alors c'est des
crèches mais croyez-moi que c'est
efficace mais encore une fois comme je
l'ai dit au lendemain de ma mission pour
les crèches même avant de la commencer
pour pouvoir écouter les choses les gens
qui vous parlent que vous écoutez et eux
vous écoutent alors évidemment on n pas
dupe suivant qui on est en face de soi
mais enfin c'est c'est c'est c'est l'EFF
c'est c'est l'effectivité d'un dialogue
voilà on parle pas toujours aux
personnes qui sont d'accord avec vous et
encore encore heureux sinon les choses
avanceraient pas très vite mais ce que
je voulais dire c'est que je veux pas
faire la révolution comme j'ai dit au
sortir de mon rapport sur les crèches il
faut y aller on a pris du retard on le
sait pour la PMI c'était le même sujet
enfin le même sujet effectif de euh
voilà il y a de la disparité
territoriale sans parler tout ce que je
vous ai précité auparavant dans mes
précédentes interventions ce qu'il faut
c'est y aller on a la volonté d'y aller
avec ma ma corapporteur Isabelle
Santiago on y va ça fait parler dans les
chaumières pas que chez les parents et
les parents vont être contents moi je
vous le dis les parents sont
contents les professionnels qui
encadrent toutes ces fédérations qui
œuvrent pour sont contents même avant de
rentrer dans cette salle au téléphone on
a lu votre vos préconisations parce
qu'on leura pas tout tout tout tout
donné en prémise mais et ils sont très
contents et je vous assure que
comprennent toutes les crèches dans leur
globalité c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
l'actualité nous en a fait part et fort
heureusement des dysfonctionnements il y
a eu une mort il y a eu un mort d'un
bébé et ça on s'en souvient tout le long
et on s'en souviendra encore pas
seulement parce qu'on a fait la mission
de de de ce bébé qui est décédé mais
pour éviter qu'il y en ait d'autres il
faut mettre du contrôle à tous les
niveaux et c'est ce qu'on est c'est ce
qu' écoutez c'est un rapport ou autant
de contrôle dans un rapport je pense pas
qu'il y en ait eu beaucoup de rapport de
ce typelà et franchement euh moi je suis
très fière de l'avoir mené encore une
fois avec Isabelle Santiago et sous sous
sous les hospices puisque c'est c'était
le bureau de de cette délégation qui a
décidé de de cette mission je suis très
très Fiè de de de de l'avoir mené et
comme je fais tout le temps je vais
jusqu'au bout et croyez-moi j'irai
jusqu'au bout et les crèches privées par
leur mauvais leur mauvais des fois
pratiqu elles sont pas toutes comme ça
vous le savez aussi bien que moi et ça
va faire encore parler dans les
chaumières chez les investisseurs comme
vous les appelez de ces crèches privé et
eux aussi ça leur fera prendre
conscience que il faut pas qu'ils fasse
n'importe quoi voilà c'est tout ce que
j'avais à dire
merci merci Michel donc très rapidement
euh sur les conseils de crèche en fait
pour les élus locaux que nous sommes
avec de l'expérience euh juste vous dire
l'exemple et c'est là que c'est ce que
j'appelle des bonnes pratiques c'est que
quand vous avez dans vos structures à
l'échelle d'un territoire municipal
voire départemental ce qui était mon cas
plus vous avez aussi euh des crèches
privées associatives et crèche privée
lucrative en fait l'idée et c'est donc
possible c'est de mettre en place le
conseil de crèche comme je l'ai dit dans
chacune des crèches ça c'est le
fonctionnement comme quand on est
délégué de parents à l'école maternelle
hein donc c'est voilà on discute du
sujet qui concerne euh la structure et
euh et et l'ensemble de la pédagogie des
enfants et ca ça c'est très important ça
se réunit trois fois par an au minimum
et autant que de besoins concernant le
parent délégué de la section élu bien
sûr parce qu'on est élu chaque année
donc section bébé section moyen section
grand section âge mélangé si c'est le
cas voilà mais on a une représentation
du parent qui est le lien et
l'interlocuteur à l'intérieur de la
structure quand le conseil de crèche se
réuni sur proposition de l'adjoint par
délégation évidemment du maire ou par le
maire si on est sur des plus petites
communes il est évident que l'ensemble
de ces conseils de crèche et ses
représentants sont invités à y
participer et souvent par expérience là
aussi ça marche plutôt très bien quand
la coordination il y a toujours dans les
en tout cas dans les grandes communes
au-dessus de 20000 habitants il y a
souvent un coordinateur petit enfance
municipal donc toute l'année en vue des
commissions de
l'obtention des places en crèche en vue
du travail avec la PMI pour une visite à
telle ou telle structure tout le monde
se connaît et tout le monde y compris
quand une crèche privée a laissé une
famille en difficulté en lui disant bah
le petit là je le gardais mais je le
garde plus à partir du mois prochain
qu'est-ce qu'ils font la famille Vienne
évidemment voir l'élu de secteur ou le
coordinateur petit enfance de la
municipalité pour dire bah moi je suis
dans la mise et surtout mon enfant
comment on fait donc au-delà du fait que
nous on a on a centré sur les besoins
fondamentaux des enfants et que il est
inabsectable que ce genre de chose
continue et donc on veut le supprimer et
croyez-moi que ça ça va faire quand même
bouger parce qu'en terme de rentabilité
ben en effet il y aura pas de
rentabilité pour 3 mois sur le dos de
d'un bébé ça c'est hors de question en
fait donc du coup forcément tout ça est
en lien et donc il est tout à fait
possible que ce conseil de crèche
fonctionne à l'échelle du territoire peu
importe l'organisation et le privé pas
privé et cetera donc je crois que c'est
l'usage de ces bonnes pratiques là qui
renforce en tout cas pour les
collectivités à l'échelle de leur
territoire la puissance en fait publique
dans l'intérêt général et des
concitoyens bien sûr des citoyens de la
commune d'avoir une référence forte en
matière de petite enfance et de lieu de
dialogue et ça je crois que c'est aussi
l'esprit pour le congrès des maires
c'est une très très bonne idée mais
personnellement là au moment où on se
parle j'ai pas mais si on est invité au
congrès du maire je vous le dis tout de
suite on sera ravi d'aller échanger
autour de ces sujets parce que je crois
qu'en fait le lien doit se faire autant
il faut une politique globale pour une
visibilité globale de nos concitoyens
français euh avec ce que l'on veut pour
la petite enfant ça devrait être quelque
chose de connu et et de lisible mais par
contre ce qui est certain c'est qu'après
ça s rigle dans les territoires parce
que chaque territoire a évidemment sa
spécificité et donc ça c'est ça me
semble important mais nous on sera en
tout cas si c'est pas au Congrès des
mères je vous rassure que on va échanger
en tout cas autour de ces questions et
puis le dernier point que mon collègue
avait posé il est clair que cette
mission flash de 3 semaines elle ne
s'est pas du tout centrée sur la
stratégie financière des fonds de
pension alors là franchement j'avoue ça
ne nous a pas traversé l'esprit parce
que nous on a répondu à une demande sur
une mission flash qui est très claire de
se positionner sur l'accueil des enfants
dans les crèches suite au rapport de
Ligas dans le cadre d'en plus de nos
territoires le regret qu'on a c'est en
effet on l'a dit c'est que 3 semaines
c'est très court et un agenda très
chargé fait que on n'a pas pu faire la
partie outreem qui est extrêmement là
aussi nécessaire en terme de
collectivité et comment on peut
accueillir encore mieux les enfants et
certainement qu'il y avait aussi des
spécificités qu'on aurait pu mettre dans
ce rapport donc ça c'est notre regret
parce que c'était que 3 semaines mais en
effet la question des fonds de pension
elle n'a pas été abordé sous l'emprise
sur laquelle vous vous le faites nous
par contre on s'est positionné et je
l'ai dit et j'ai redit pourquoi sur les
besoins des enfants de la petite enfance
donc évidemment très prignante dans
cette je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
dans cette dans ce positionnement très
clair que l'on a pris ont fait plusieurs
mesures qui je vous confirme vraiment et
vous le savez d'ailleurs euh
sont
intransigentes pour le secteur du privé
qui voudrait déroger aux règles que on
va mettre en place et que l'on propose
de mettre en place parce que je vous
disais même sur le berceau réservataire
entre guillemets en attendant l' tente
d'entreprise qui vient avec le le
berceau et bien il y a sacrément un
paradigme de changement donc voilà donc
du coup honnêtement je crois que comme
toute mission de 3 semaines je crois que
c'est un énorme travail qu'on a fait et
qui est une belle réalisation maintenant
à mettre en œuvre merci Isabelle alors
n'allez pas tous au salon des maères la
semaine du 21 22 23 novembre parce que
je vous rappelle que c'est également la
semaine des droits de l'enfant et donc
que nous avons pas mal d'événements au
niveau de la délégation vous avez reçu
l'agenda on compte sur vous notamment on
a un colloc sport aujourd'hui on a du
mal à le faire diffuser n'hésitez pas à
le diffuser autour de vous pour qu'on
ait du monde je avant que vous partiez
on a une formalité administrative est-ce
qu'il y a des personnes qui sont contre
la publication de ce rapport qui
s'abstiennent bien il est publié je vous
remercie et je vous souhaite une bonne
semaine et donc rendez-vous mardi
prochain vous pourrez interroger la
ministre sur ce rapport et sur d'autres
propositions que vous voudriez faire sur
la petite enfance